This is a smart list. Coming right at you. Oh, that's genius. Yes, wonderful. And cue the music. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
Jason, hi, sorry, so stressful. That is so stressful. We have sometimes, every once in a while, we'll have tech difficulties. Yeah, listener, we apologize if we were late today. Well, would we have been late with the listener? How does it work? Not like that.
But it's a good, I get where you're going with it. And yeah, more an apology to our special guest. Yeah, I'm so sorry, special guest. Who Sean and I don't know who it is yet. Yeah, so sorry. Well, let me tell you something, Will. You're going to be mortified when you realize that you've embarrassed yourself. You and your silly podcast operation have embarrassed yourself in front of this guest.
Why? How did I do it? I'm not in charge of Sean. Yeah, but you're going to feel the most embarrassment because... No, no, no. That should be... It's not even... I mentioned Scottie. This one's firmly on Scottie, and I feel like this is his department, he's in the tech department over at their house, and he's head of IT and he fucked up. I know nothing, I know nothing.
I hand him my iPhone. Where is Scottie today, what's his excuse? He's working in the back in his little studio. So he's doing his things instead of doing your things. That's right. There's the problem. Priorities have shifted. Yeah, they have shifted.
We should bring him in front of the council. Yeah. And he probably can't step away from those duties for 10 minutes, can he? No, no, he can't. Yeah. Yeah. It'd be the 12 steps that it takes him to walk
from the back to the front. By the way, Jay, I didn't know that Franny was in 9 to 5. Yes, yes. I would have completely seen that. Oh my God, you would have loved it. Yes, so Franny, Tracy, my 17-year-old, she was in a musical last week at her school. She was incredible, I can say.
I heard she was great, yeah. Yeah, and I'm just so, so proud. And she seems to, unfortunately, have been bitten by the actor bug, the performance bug, the audience bug, the whole thing. I bet. And so, you know, we're gonna have to manage that. I'm obviously gonna support her.
No, I mean, I've tried. I heard she played Roz, right? Did she sing the theme song, like the title song? As part of the ensemble, yes. It was, now, 9 to 5 was on Broadway at one point, was it not? Correct, yes. It, Nine to Five was on Broadway at one point, was it not? Correct, yes, uh-huh. It seemed like it's a great show.
Yeah, I heard it's really good. The whole tumble out of bed, stumble to the kitchen, pour myself a cup of ambition, yawn and stretch and try to come alive. Oh, you know the song. I've never seen Jason. I saw it three times last week. And Maple, our 12 year old,
she was maybe even more obsessed by the whole experience. Yes, she told me. There are two on the loading dock. Here it comes, Hollywood Better Get Ready. Maple liked it a lot too, huh? Yeah, she loved it. She's gonna get into theater when she gets to the upper school.
Really? She says she's not interested in the tech part at all. Yeah, she doesn't wanna get her hands dirty building sets and light cues and stuff like that. She just wants a spotlight. But it was very, very cool. I loved it. It's fun to watch that, right?
Now, Jay, the painting behind you, you painted that or you bought that? It seems like to watch that. The painting behind you, you painted that or you bought that or? It seems like it's some, like I would, I know, it's a little frame heavy left. Let me adjust my composition there. Let's do that. There we go. Let's go me and.
Oh, look at that nice kitchenette. It looks like flowers, but it's actually a broom. All right, sorry listener. You know what, it's been too long now. We've kept our guest waiting because of Scotty ignoring you, Sean. So let me do my best. Sean, just have a deep, deep pool of milk though
before we get the guest out here. Yeah, have a good one. He truly did, listener. Just a big, hard shot of milk. So this is a fella that, Will would probably do a better job introducing this guy. And he probably will be driving this interview much more than me, although I am a huge fan of his as well.
But I can't really elaborate with one of my incredible introductions like I usually do. When do you do those? But I will. Sean, what did he say? So I will say that, well, let me, I'm gonna say some things here, and Willie as soon as you guess it you can go ahead And introduce them. All right. All right
This guy this stud this world famous athlete in the room played for Manchester United Real Madrid AC Milan LA-Germain, and the England National Team. David Beckham, are you kidding me? David Beckham, get out here. What? No way!
Okay? Oh my God. No, I'm not joking. You're welcome, Will. I'm joking. It's not even your birthday. Wait, I'm so sorry for keeping you waiting. Don't worry.
Shut up, Sean. It doesn't have damage already. You't worry. Shut up, Sean. You've done enough damage already. You shut your mouth. David, thank you for joining us. It's a pleasure. Thank you for having me on. This is so exciting to me
because I knew nothing about football, soccer. Watched the documentary. It's all I can stop talking about. It was incredible. I can't stop talking about it. It was incredible. We're gonna get to that. And the fact that you had to spend so much time with Fisher Stevens shows what great resolve
you have as a human being. Well... Fisher's our friend. He's amazing. He's amazing. It took us a while to find him as a director. You know, I looked for a long time for the right person to help me tell the story.
And the moment I met him, I knew he was firstly, unfortunately, he was a Liverpool fan, like you will, but other than that, he's a great guy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. David, what an absolute thrill to meet you, my friend. This is so cool. I'm such a massive fan. First of all, where are we finding you?
I'm actually in London okay I'm just I've been in the office all day and then I have a premiere of a Friends series on Netflix tonight so I'm I'm heading there after after here but that's why I've got a shirt and tie on yeah I was gonna say now let me guess is this is or is this for Ripley? This is Guy Ritchie's series tonight. So he's doing the Gentleman series. I've seen the movie, but the series he's been working on for a while, so I'm heading there tonight.
I think he's a great director. Well, it's no surprise, and you made an excuse for wearing a shirt and tie, but you always look really, really well turned out. Sorry you're not good looking. He's working on it. He's trying to distract from his ugly looks by dressing up a bit.
No, but I was gonna say. We do what we can. You do what you can. You follow, that is something that has been a trademark of yours. You've always been kind of into style and into fashion and that comes through in the doc, series about your life.
Do you feel pressure in that? I always want to know, do you feel pressure in that way because you've set this standard? Like you're like, oh shit, I better look good when I go to the store. Yes, to be honest, not at all. I never feel pressure on that side. I think my wife added to the fashion side of my life when
we met 27 years ago. But even before then, you know, I was always into fashion even at eight years old when I tell the story about when I was a page boy at one of our friends weddings, my mum's friend's wedding. And she asked me if I wanted to wear a suit or I wanted to wear tights and a pair of ballet shoes, and I chose the tights and ballet shoes. So, in all honesty, I never feel pressure. I enjoy wearing suits, I enjoy wearing casual clothes, but I never feel the pressure to look in any certain way. But so you have a position somewhere in the English government
or somehow with the fashion industry. I should have this and I'm looking for it. I don't have it here. Great research. Yeah, it's not great over here. Sorry, David. But can you fill in where my dumbness is taking over? Yeah, I do a lot for the Fashion Council, which they made me-
Sounds like the Ministry of Magic. They kind of made me an ambassador of the Fashion Council. And it was something that I was quite surprised about, but in all honesty, it's something that I've loved to be part of because it's about the new generation and the next generation of talented young designers. And that's what I love doing. The work that I do on the charity side, the work that I've done on the soccer side over the years,
it's all about the young talent and bringing them through. It's one of the reasons why I started the team in Miami, because I was excited about the talented players that we have in Florida, in South Florida, and obviously in Miami, and that excited me more than anything. So, you know, stepping into the fashion world in that way was exciting for me.
Well, here's the thing about fashion, because to me. Oh go ahead, yeah, let's hear it from the expert. Everyone's been dying to hear. So just, when you tie the baseball cap into the t-shirt, tell us what the process is. Definitely interrupt David Beckham to get your opinion on fashion, go ahead. No, but my thing is like, Scotty always,
my husband Scotty always wishes I, Another fashion firestorm. Always wishes I would dress better, right? Like, he's like, are you really gonna walk out of the house looking like that, can't you just put some nice pants and nice shirt? And I was like, you know, the looseness of a t-shirt and the looseness of, it's more comfortable to me. Yeah, that's what it is, and to me, comfort was like, you know, the looseness of a t-shirt and the looseness of, like, it's more comfortable.
To me, like, yeah, that's what it is. And to me, comfort is like, I don't like dressing in a shirt and a tie, because it's so restricting and the pants are tight and the tuxedo, like, and you enjoy that? Well, if it fits right, if it fits right, then it's comfortable. So most of the time it does.
So I feel okay doing that. But I, you know. But most of the day you'd like to be in sweats in a t-shirt. Absolutely. Or jeans in a t-shirt. Yeah, of course. Now can I ask you David, do you like a little bit of stretch in your jeans?
I do. I do. It's nice to have a little bit of stretch in the jeans. I get a lot of heat for the stretch I prefer in my jeans. But you know, us athletes, David, we've got nice-sized legs and a real motor behind us. And so we need some room when we sit down. We need room in our jeans. I agree.
Jason's a little different from you, David, in that he's got the kind of thighs that are made for playing video games. You know what I mean? It looks like he's been sitting in... He's got atrophied limbs. Well, to be honest, I was a fan of Ozark, so I saw those thighs quite a lot of times.
Oh, you. This is, take your time through this section, David. They look good, they look good. Thank you. He's a very handsome boy. I'm shy. To wrap up the fashion side of it, I'm curious, Will, I'm curious if you like going to these fashion shows.
Do you like sitting front row and seeing all the fashion forward stuff? To be honest, I very rarely go to the shows other than my wife's show. You know, I've gone to a couple of the shows over the years, but I don't go to as many as people think I do. But the ones that I have to go to now, and I want to go to, obviously, are my wife's ones.
So I enjoy that. Does she make men's clothing? She doesn't yet. She made me a pair of jeans, actually. She should send you a pair and they fit well. So she made me a pair of jeans the other day. So we'll see. I don't know what she's going to go into next,
but she's doing very well. She's a very hardworking woman. So yeah, we'll see. I don't know what she's gonna go into next, but she's doing very well. She's a very hardworking woman, so, uh, yeah, we'll see. She's always looking for new projects. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I think I saw a video of you at the show the other day, and she came over and gave you a big kiss, right? Well, she gave me a big kiss because obviously it was quite an emotional one for her.
These shows are always emotional for obviously the work that she puts in, and then it's over in like eight minutes. That's what I'm saying. So, yeah. So I got invited to an Armani one in Milan. Yeah. So I flew halfway across the world,
because I'd never been to a fashion show. Who's male were you accidentally getting that week? Fuck. So we fly around, halfway around the world, I go sit in the front row of this Armani fashion show, it's two minutes long. Yeah, I know, I know. I'm like, what?
It is amazing, but she was emotional because she's also got a broken foot at the moment. Oh, yes. So she broke her foot. Funny story, we went skiing. She came for two days. She kept on saying, I'm not gonna ski, I'm not gonna ski because I've got too much going on.
So she then went home after two days, left me with all the kids. She was stretching in the gym. And by the way, Victoria is the biggest fan of the podcast, by the way. Is she? Oh no way. She's so sweet. And we love her. This morning, I don't think I've actually never had so many texts from her during the day on the lead up to this. She actually texts me at three o'clock. She was like, have you done the podcast yet?
And I was like, no. And then this morning at breakfast, she was like, okay, I'm going to give you some pointers. Don't try and be funny. She said, you guys usually focus on actors and not so much athletes. Obviously, I've listened to a few of the athletes you've had on. But she was like, don't talk too much about soccer because these guys are intelligent. The people that are listening to these podcasts are people like me, she said.
So she said, I don't want to listen to soccer the whole way through this. So, you know. Right, right. We're gonna cover a little bit of it and Tracy's just gonna have to deal with it. Believe me, first of all, let's say that we're fans of Victoria's. Yeah, huge, huge, huge.
First and foremost, and so hello, Victoria. I'm a huge fan, yeah. Secondly, I'm sorry to say that when she says we're intelligent, she must be talking about a different podcast. Thirdly, we're gonna talk about football, AKA soccer, which by the way, we covered this. Soccer is actually an English term,
everybody thinks it's an American term, but you David probably know. Soccer is an abbreviation of association football, and they called it Soc-er, right David? Yep, that's true. No, I didn't know that. Yeah, it's not American. So, David, so let's get into it. Where did's get where did the ER come from song like the way they do
rugby and they call it rugger it was the same idea they was kind of right David by the way this is the first time I'm hearing this so I'm just agreeing with you will it's just oh yeah it's true so the way that's amazing rugby and they and they call that rugger is like a sort of a slangy version and soccer or football is called association football to distinguish it from rugby. It's called association football and then they just took the sock from association and called it soccer. Anyway. Wow. I think we just ran out of time. Yeah, thanks for joining us David. David, so listen, so you started playing football
when you were a kid and your dad, and I love that they cover this in the documentary, your dad was a huge Man U fan growing up. And then you go and become one of the great Man U players, when you say Manchester United, you think David Beckham. But you started the Man U Academy as a little kid, right? Well, I'm an East End boy, so I'm from the East End of London.
And obviously I started actually at Tottenham's Academy and Arsenal's Academy as a young kid. Oh. So. What about West Ham? Were you? Yeah, West Ham wanted me to go down and train with them, but I was obviously, at that point,
I was having to decide between Arsenal and Tottenham. My grandfather was a season ticket holder for 50 years at Spurs at Tottenham, so I decided to go with Tottenham. So I spent a couple of years training at Tottenham, till I was 12 years old, and then Manchester United noticed me down in London. They invited me up to Manchester,
and that's when it all started, and I moved up to Manchester when I was 15. Wow. And let me bring Sean into the conversation. Sean, when David said that he's an East End boy, did you start humming Pet Shop Boys to yourself? Absolutely. Don't lie.
Yeah, me too. I love that song. Wait, but I have a question about the doc, because now I know everything about you, and I'm obsessed with you like the west of the world. And so, because- Like the west of the world? By the way, are you just gonna go off topic
because we're just getting on- No, no, it's about soccer. It's about football. So because in the documentary, the thing that blew my mind was when the whole country turned on you in that moment, that right in the moment in the documentary, and the moment in your career.
And I was at home not knowing anything, not involved with the ins and outs of the crowd and the game and everything like that. I'm going, why are they booing the greatest player? They should be supporting you. So what is the mob mentality of turning on the best player in England? In the world?
I think the English have always had that mentality of build someone up, knock them down, and then watch them get out of that again. And once they get out of that, there's a lot more respect there. But I think, you know, I made a mistake in 1998 with the red card and I owned up to that mistake and then I had to spend the next three or four years trying to get through these games and the seasons and the abuse that I was getting. But I think, to your point, Sean, that I think one of the things that came out
of the documentary is the fact that everyone in America remembers me playing for the Galaxy. They remember me playing for my country and also other teams that I played for, but they didn't know the story of what I'd gone through. And so every time that I'm in Miami or LA or New York or somewhere in the US, people come up to me and were like, we didn't know that story.
Like, just like you've said, and I suppose for a lot of people, the documentary was a reminder of firstly how bad it was and sometimes also for people to actually know the story. So it was it was quite hard talking for it actually. It humanizes and you know look you at a certain point you and you know this David and certainly you guys know this to a different degree not the same way that David does but you become you are your own person but then the public owns you in a way they own this idea of you and you play for you play
for England you Captain England you they kind of in their mind they kind of own you so if you fuck up in whatever way that they perceive they're like hey man you go you don't get to you don't get to make mistakes. You don't get to be human. And too fucking, oh boo hoo David, oh you're rich, famous. And it's like, well I'm still a person who wakes up in the morning and makes mistakes. Yeah, and you can't hide, I'll bet, right?
I mean, England is such a small place in comparison to America. There's not a corner you can go without having to be ready for either confrontation or adulation. I know a couple corners in London I can show you. Go ahead. We'll be right back.
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. If you're in a relationship like I am, although mine's pretty wonderful, 18 years, but if you're in a relationship and we all go through things and times when you kind of stuff some feelings and you keep it inside, but if you keep it inside too long, you're just gonna blow up later.
So you have to learn how to get things off your chest and in a respectful kind of way so that people will hear it instead of not hearing it and fight back. And I had to learn that through therapy. And because we all carry around different stressors, big and small, when we keep them bottled up, it can start to affect us negatively. Therapy is a safe space to get things off your chest
and to figure out how to work through whatever's weighing you down. It's important to check in with yourself and listen to what your body and mind is telling you. A therapist can help you recognize triggers or signs of burnout so you stay in touch with what you need. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try.
It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Get it off your chest with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month.
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. Smartlis is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener.
As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. I just discovered Audible does thrillers like in the best way, and recently I just picked out one called Before She Dies by Mary Burton. It's really cool. I'll read the log line here at the end. It says, as a madman's body count rises, Detective Daniel Rolkoff is drawn into a mission that's become terrifyingly personal.
That kind of grabbed me, and when I started listening, I was like, ooh, I gotta learn more, and I did, and it's so good. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless, or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless, or text smartless to 500 500,
to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartlis or text smartlis to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartlis Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of smartlis It's winner take all time in the NBA and NHL and FanDuel is giving you a shot to bring home a big win of your own Right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's 150 bucks to bet on spreads, money lines, player props, and more. It'd be pretty cool to bet on how long I can stay away
from our dog Ricky. Because we go out to dinner, and that time seems to get shorter and shorter because I'm obsessed with him being alone. And people have even said, we should bet on you how long you can last outside of your home. I bet you'd be a close call. Somebody would win something.
Visit fandual.com slash smartless and make every playoff shot count. Fandual, America's number one sports book. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. Is there a place on the planet that you found that you can go and you can have relative anonymity and just bop around?
Well, one of my, you know, and I talk about it in a documentary after the World Cup, the place where I went was New York because Victoria was there with the Spice Girls and she was on tour and my escape was New York. So I thought, you know, no one really kind of knew me in the US at that point. They kind of knew who I, some soccer fans knew who I was, but actually me, yeah, but me actually going there was an escape for me.
But then the media was so intense at that point. You know, I kind of disappeared for a few weeks, and then by the time I came back, I thought, and I talk about it in the documentary, I thought, oh, they'd have forgot everything, and they didn't. So it was kind of difficult at the time. But obviously being with a Spice Girl at that time, they were at the time. But obviously being with a spy skill at that time, they
were at the height of their fame. So it was kind of both worlds colliding. And I think that's why probably I got some of the abuse that I got. And in all honesty, I accepted it, I got on with it, and I knew the only way of me getting over it was working harder and being protected by Sir Alex Ferguson. I know, but you were so young to go through that process and to learn that that's how you get out of it. Like, how do you, you're so young.
Was it comforting at all to know that in England that is kind of what white hot fame looks like, that's the kind of treatment that you get, so therefore need not take it too personally, it's just that's the way they kind of do media there. Well, I suppose you do think like that to a certain point, but you do take a lot of the stuff that is going on personally. You know, a lot of the things that are being said,
but I kind of knew deep down, even though I'd not been through anything like that throughout my career up until that point, I knew deep down that I would be okay. I don't know how, I just knew that I was protected at Manchester United, I was protected by Sir Alex Ferguson, but the thing that I got upset mostly about was, my grandparents got affected by it, my sisters,
my parents, and that was what upset me more than anything. Yeah, yeah. Well, let me ask you this, David, and it comes out, it's something that I've always sort of suspected, but it comes out glaringly in the docu-series, and is that, how much is that support of, like you mentioned your family, Sir Alex Ferguson, how much was having that core group
of people supporting you? Was that the thing that got you through? Yeah, that was exactly what got me through. You know, obviously, my friends and my family, you know, I've always had good, close friends, and my family are an incredible support for me. They always have been. Um, and I've been lucky with that throughout my whole career,
even at, you know at a very young age, my parents supported me with whatever I did. But the one thing that got me through on the football side was the support of Sir Alex Ferguson, was the support of Manchester United, and probably the biggest was my teammates and the fans, because every other stadium that I went to around the world, I got abused.
But at Old Trafford, whenever I went to around the world, I got abused. But at Old Trafford, you know, whenever I went over and took a corner or a free kick, you know, the whole stand, like, jumped up. And that was, and that was, like, it was like a big family. So, you know, that's what got me. Yeah, you and your player, you and your teammates were like brothers.
I've seen a few different things. I saw that one. I forget what it was. It was the five of you kind of reminiscing and going... Do you remember that we came out a couple years ago? The Class of 92. Class of 92. Yeah.
So good. I watched that when I was in the UK a couple years ago. I just loved it. And obviously known as potentially the greatest dead ball kicker of all time. I mean, you had a movie named after you, Ben, like, back in... Yeah, that's so cool. That's insane. It was kind of amazing, actually.
Do Sean, if they did it for you, they'd do, eat sloppy joes like Sean or something. You know what I mean? Wipe your mouth like Sean did. But, hang on, hang on, hang on. But what I want to get into is, you and your teammates, you guys had that Class of 92, one of the great all-time classes.
I remember watching you guys, what was it, 99, when you guys were down, was it Champions League and you won it, you got the two extra goals. Two goals in three minutes, yeah, wow. It was un-fucking-believable. And so who were the tight guys in that group? It was, name them. Well, we were all tight in all honesty.
But obviously the lads that grew up together was me, Gary Neville, Phil Neville, Nicky Butt, Paul Skolls, Ryan Giggs. So we all grew up, like that was the class of 92 because obviously we all came through in 1992 the Neville brothers Those are the Neville brothers Gary Neville who's very outspoken and he's constantly constantly sparring with my guy Jamie Carragher who's a who's a Liverpool player? Gary is always on Sky Sports saying something controversially. Can't help himself. Is that right?
I love that. That is exactly right. And he's always been the same. He's always been controversial. He's always been able to talk a lot. And the funny thing, the relationship between him and Jamie Carragher, they used to hate each other as players. We all, you know, that rivalry was so intense, but they're best of friends now, which is amazing to see. I have a feeling Victoria is about to come in
and stab David with her headphones. I feel like this is the weed she's talking about. I wish I was at home and I'd bring her in, trust me. She actually said to me at breakfast, she was like, we should have done it, why am I not doing it? She was like, ah! That's true, Why am I not doing it? She was like, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna give her her own hour. I will just say this and then we'll leave it. I feel like I'm the David Beckham of this, of my crew of this marvelous crew. These guys are my supporting. We're the ball. And I would, except for the looks, the fashion and the athletic ability.
Barely, barely. Now, David, what part of the documentary were you most excited for the public to learn about you that perhaps they didn't know before? To be honest, I was nervous about the whole thing. When I retired eight years before, or 10 years before, it was actually 10 years, people wanted someone, they wanted me to do it then and there, there and then. And I wasn't actually ready to kind of look back. I was ready to kind of just jump into something else,
which was the club in Miami. But then about two years out from my 10 year retirement, kind of anniversary, we started to discuss it and talk about it and think, okay, maybe this is the right time. So I don't know. In all honesty, one of the reasons why I wanted to do the documentary was for my family. I wanted them to have something all in one place
for them to watch and for them to look back and reminisce. And that's what really we created. There was a hell of a story there from the upbringing to the different clubs that I played for, to the ups and the downs. And my career was always kind of a roller coaster, but obviously I was very lucky to be as successful as I was because of the teams that I played for
and the teammates that I had. Right, and now did you have, like, was there a moment where you thought, how am I going to chase this high of all of the success that I had, and if not, what made you get out of that feeling of like, God, I can't chase this high forever, like, what am I gonna do?
Well, in all honesty, I'm shocked with the reaction to the documentary. I can't believe the reaction that we've had to the documentary. You should be surprised that even I watched it. In my wildest dreams, I couldn't have, you know, I wasn't expecting all of what has happened since we brought it out have, you know, I wasn't expecting all of what has happened since we bought it out. But, you know, with chasing the higher, you know, I knew that
once I finished my career, I kind of planned it 10 years out, you know, before I retired. I didn't know when I was going to retire, but I always knew that I needed to step into something new. On the day that I retired, the day after, I knew that I'd have to go again, because that's just how I was brought up. My parents worked really hard, and they luckily built that into me, so I was ready to go straight after that. And nothing was gonna replace the feeling of playing soccer,
but I knew I needed to be busy How far after you how long after you retired was it that you purchased? Miami inter miami well, I announced I had to actually be finished playing soccer so When I signed for la I put that in my contract so I could buy a franchise at the end of my time Of playing in LA. And luckily they gave it to me. And it was for half the price of what they were worth at the time. And then obviously six years later I was able to announce it.
And then I was playing in Paris. My last game was in Paris. And the day after I flew to Miami and I announced the team in Miami. The day after. Wow, that's really cool. How are you liking that new role in the process, the role of ownership? You know what, it's been one of the most challenging things
that I've ever done. Whether in my career or outside of my career in the business side. Because we had to jump over a lot of like hurdles along the way. There was so many difficult moments, people turning around and saying, Miami is a really difficult sporting city.
Don't go there, don't take the team there. But I had a feeling that that was where I wanted to take the team. And it took a long time to get it up and running. And we're still jumping through different challenges, but in all honesty, my vision from day one when I presented the team and tried to put the logo together and the colors and all of that,
the last slide of the presentation that I presented to the creative guys was a picture of Messi in the Miami Jersey. So my dream was always to bring someone and him to our team. Unbelievable. I mean, how crazy that you've been,
you're Messi's boss. I mean, let's just, you know, let's not dress up. I can't look at it like that. I can't, I just can't. But it's pretty wild. And you, not only have you been successful with this team in Miami, but you brought over Leo Messi in a time when, and as you are well aware, a lot of players are going east to get those big, you know,
inserts of riches in the Middle East. Yeah. A lot of players from Europe, in search of riches in the Middle East. Yeah. A lot of players from Europe, a lot of players from the UK, they're all going there and getting these huge paydays. Famously, Ronaldo and everybody else. And Messi comes to Miami. And that must've felt like a real vindication for you, like a real sort of vote of confidence that he said,
you know what, I'm gonna go to Miami and I'm gonna partner with David Beckham and I'm gonna play for Miami. I mean, that must have felt good. It felt unbelievable, and I still can't believe it. Every time someone turns around to me and says, you have Messi in your team, you realize that, don't you? And it really is surreal, you know,
to say that we have probably the greatest player to have ever played the game, the most successful player to ever play the game, and he's playing in Miami in the MLS. But Leo, his vision was always, you know, he turned around to me many years ago, he said, I love Miami, one day I want to live in Miami, and it stuck in my head. And I thought, I'm going to make that happen one day. If ever we ever get a chance to bring a player like him and his caliber to Miami, then that's what I want to do.
So it took a lot of time. We started the process four or five years before he came. Wow. I sneaked into his dad's hotel. You know, I said, I want to sign your son. I know he won't come now, but at some point, we want to bring him to Miami. So we started the process five years out, and then all of a sudden, he decides to come. And yeah, I actually cannot believe.
But you're right. A lot of players were wanting to go and go into Saudi at the time, and he had a lot of offers, obviously, on the table. But he's very clever. You know, he's very clever. He knows what a massive market the US market is, the opportunities that you can have. I think he also saw the life that me,
the kids and my wife had in LA. And you know, that was his decision. Yeah, I mean, and then you also got Suarez and Jordi Alba. I know. It's quite aba. I know, yeah. Sergio Busquets, I know. I do get a little bit of stick from my Madrid mates because we're building a Barcelona team at the moment.
So at some point, we might have to bring some Madrid players in, but yeah, it's very exciting. Well, obviously, bringing these global superstars into American soccer is hugely important. It's something that you basically started, if I'm correct, and the sport has consequently been growing in the United States quite a lot since then. Since you started playing for the galaxy, basically.
Yeah, yeah, and so you kinda started a thing going there and it's reached its zenith, current zenith with Messi. Are you bullish, are you confident that American soccer will continue to grow and someday be on par with our American football and baseball and basketball as far as notoriety and attendance and licensing and TV rights, all that stuff? At the end of the day, it's hard to be as big as baseball, American football, basketball, because it's just what it is.
But I think we have a real opportunity with soccer in the MLS and in the US. And I was bullish back in 2007. I knew that firstly, moving from Real Madrid to the LA Galaxy, when at that time, I think there was 13 or 14 teams in the league, the league wasn't as established as it was. There wasn't a big TV deal there. There wasn't a big Apple deal. All of these things weren't in place. So I arrived and it wasn't as professional
as I'm used to. But I knew that I wanted that challenge. I knew that I wanted, I always loved the US. I always wanted to live in US. And my decision at that time was criticized, like quite heavily. And I was criticized as an athlete at that time. But I wanted that, you know, I wanted that challenge. And I could see. You know, I wanted that challenge and I could see, you know, what the future looked like in the MLS. And luckily, there's been a lot of people that have really put a lot behind, you know, this league. And now it's gone from one extreme to the other.
And now, you know, we need to continue to grow it. And what can we do to sort of grow the sport? I really, you know, as you pointed out, I'm a massive Liverpool fan. By the way, my only piece of advice I'll ever give you, David, when it comes to football, because you're one of the all-time greats, I will say this, is, and you've got a good coach manager over at Inter Miami, but you know what I'm gonna say
who needs to come in, because he's about to be available. He's my guy. I know, and you know what? If gonna say who needs to come in because he's about to be available. I know he's my guy I know you're gonna know what if I can bring your gun over and let me be the three Don't you start your again? You're gonna get it. You're gonna get an earful I must admit even as a men's United fan. I love you again. I I love I love his character I love his personality you know, I love what he brings to the sport. And, you know, to hear him say that he's leaving Liverpool, and obviously being a Manchester United fan,
I'm going to get killed by some of my Manchester United friends. But I'm sad to see him leave. I'm sad. You know, what he's done for the club and what he's done for the sport, has been incredible. Pull him close to your breast in Miami? David you should know this much money left We're gonna put it together we're gonna put it together I want to help make this happen you should know a couple weeks ago I was in Canada for the for the any the hockey all-star game and they had me be like is that right?
Hey, they had me be a sort... Is that right, eh? They had me be sort of like a celebrity captain, whatever. And so I was with Connor McDavid, who's one of the greats of all time, and I gave a speech, said, you have a speech for the boys in the locker room. I said, I sure do. And what I had done was I pulled together a bunch of Jurgen Klopp quotes,
and I made it into a speech. And I started, and because all his speeches are so inspiring, right? And it kind of goes beyond sport, the way he talks to people. And then I ended it by saying, when I first came to Dortmund, and then all the players looked at me like, Dortmund, what is he talking, anyway. We're going to get you in the club.
But I want to get my question was, what can we do to make football, sort of, how can we improve it in this country, you know, whether it's youth academies or just grow the sport? Because I really want young people to play. Yeah, well, in all honesty, when I came in 2007, I sat with the commissioner, I said, okay, talk to me about the academies
that run through the MLS. He said, we don't have any. I said, OK, well then, every team has to have an academy. And I'm proud to say that every team now has academy systems that run from 12 years old up until 23. And we in Miami, that's one of the most exciting things for me, the academy, because we had six young kids in our first team last year. And those are the things that you need to do. You know, and also, you need to do that,
but you also need to bring stars. You know, bringing Leo to the league wasn't just about, you know, giving a gift to the US and the MLS and obviously to the US and the MLS and obviously to the Miami fans, it was more about what he can do for our Academy players. And continuing what you started. Gareth Bale did it too, the great Gareth Bale.
Yep, we love Gareth. We love him. He's a great golfer by the way. He's a great golfer. He's a great golfer. Good Lord. How's your golf game, David? It's okay, it's okay. I bet your golf game, David? It's okay.
It's okay. I'll bet it's pretty damn good. It's okay. Come play with us. Come play with us next time you're in LA. Okay. I'm not that good. What's your...
Gareth embarrassed us. Gareth, he literally embarrassed us. Did he, JB? Yeah. And it wasn't just the hair. No. We'll be right back. Thank you to one of our new sponsors, Liquid Death, for supporting the show. Be right back. of crisp low sugar sodas, low sugar iced teas, and refreshing mountain spring water.
But why the name Liquid Death? They're here to crush the use of single use plastic bottles with their recyclable cans. Isn't that awesome? I actually love the flavors. I love severed lime. I love mango chainsaw and cherry obituary. I love the names first of all. But all those three are so delicious.
They're yummy. You crack them open, they go right down. It's so refreshing. You can get free shipping of Liquid Death's Mountain Water flavored sparkling and iced tea, eight packs with Amazon Prime, or grab a can or a case at your local 7-Eleven, Target, Walmart, Whole Foods, or on Instacart. Go to liquiddeath.com slash smartless to check out all their healthy, infinitely recyclable beverages and find your closest retailer. That's liquiddeath.com slash smartless. Liquiddeath.com slash smartless.
We get support from State Farm. There is a lot to say when buying a new home or car, but only one thing to say that can help you protect them. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. With a State Farm agent, you know someone is there to help protect your future by helping you choose the coverage you need. With so many coverage options,
it feels good knowing you can find what fits for you. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent, or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way agent. Or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way. So when you need help protecting the
things that matter most, remember to say, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. SmartList is supported by FedEx. FedEx offers picture-proof of delivery, package-less and paper-less returns, as well as weekend home delivery to 98% of the US on Saturday and 50% on Sunday. Now that's peace of mind. For me, I can't sleep at night unless I know things are in place, there's an order to things,
and that's why I love FedEx, and that's why I love having picture-proof delivery. Don't you all love that? Knowing that they're covered because they took the picture and it's on your front step, so you know that you're covered and that they're covered. Everybody's covered at FedEx. It's such a good feeling.
It's so secure. I love it. See the FedEx Service Guide for delivery information. FedEx ground service is also faster to more locations than UPS ground. See what FedEx can do for your business. Absolutely, positively FedEx. Alice and Matt here from British Scandal. Matt, if we had a bingo card, what would be on there? Oh, compelling storytelling, egotistical white men and dubious humour.
If that sounds like your cup of tea, you will love our podcast, British Scandal, the show where every week we bring you stories from this green and not always a Schumer. If that sounds like your cup of tea, you will love our podcast, British Scandal, the show where every week we bring you stories from this green and not always so pleasant land. We've looked at spies, politicians, media magnates, a king, no one is safe. And knowing our country, we won't be out of a job anytime soon. Follow British Scandal wherever you listen to your podcasts. And now back to the show. What is your favorite sport aside from soccer that you enjoy playing and or watching? I love basketball.
Do you? Basketball? I love it. Are you a Miami Heat fan? No, I'm a Lakers fan. I've always been a Lakers fan. I've always been a Lakers fan. And then obviously when I moved to LA, I was able to go to the games every week and I made sure that I go to the game every week.
And what I found a little bit strange and I always say it that even through the early games and the middle of the season games, two minutes to go, people are leaving the seats and going home. No one wants to get caught in traffic in LA. Well, Jason needs to get home. Yeah, I gotta get home. I gotta get on the slip piece.
I always stayed right to the end, firstly because I'm a loyal fan. You're also leaving in the SUV from the tunnel under the Staples Center, what was then called the Staples Center. You don't have to deal with the nonsense of traffic getting out of the big lot. That is true. Don't embarrass him.
And you've deserved that. You've earned that. But Kobe was on the court. So there was no way I was not going to watch every second of Kobe being on the court. Yeah, I get it. So it's more about that than anything else. I'm a Lakers fan. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. I'm a Lakers fan too.
David, we have, every once in a while, we get a lucky caller will break through with a question. Oh no. I don't know if you're seeing it there on your board. Oh, this is for Will. This caller is from New York City named Justin T. Fucking Pharrell. He is so good looking.
He says here... Don't say that, don't say that. His arms are cold though. So Will, he says, he says, I love the show, Will. You've always been a huge Liverpool supporter. As you know, your guest Mr. Beckham has at times not had the warmest of receptions by Liverpool fans, but because he is a wonderful man and a top bloke,
he has generously forgiven them. My question is, as a Liverpool fan, would you like to use this moment on the record and on behalf of all Liverpoolians to apologize to Mr. Beckham's beautiful face and admit that you were wrong and you should shut your big fat mouth. That's a question.
First of all, less of a question and more of an opinion when he says shut your big fat mouth. There's a lot of opinion there. Yeah. There's a lot of. I would. Can you apologize?
I will apologize for all the Reds fans out there. Because. Wow, you're not gonna be able to go back to Anfield. I know, it's true. I'm going back to Anfield in May. Because I want to see Jurgen before he wraps it up. But no, I will apologize for rude behavior. For sure I will. Looks like he's got a follow-up question here. He's got a follow-up question also for Will.
At night, do you use moisturizer on your chest or just regular prescription burn cream? And he says he can just take the answer off air. He's hanging up now. He's unbelievable. Yeah. David, I have a question for... I know.
We all do. He's got great arms. What is the arms... Why has he always got his arms up? Yeah We all do The arms why is he go always got his arms up? Yeah. Well, why would you why would you hide them? I mean if you've got those arms, I've never Somebody's in such good shape for somebody who's so unathletic You throw a ball at him he runs the other direction You throw a ball at him, he runs the other direction. Oh my God. Now David, you mentioned like, you know,
my question about the documentary, about all that drama that you encountered. Just sitting here talking to you, never having met you before, you seem like the kind of guy, and I'm guessing, you strike me as someone who, that recognizes people or situations that could potentially be drama or controversy,
like you mentioned your mate that always gets himself into trouble because of all the controversy. Do you run from that now, having been through so much drama your whole life, with reporters, journalism, the field that you were in or continue to be in? Journalisms, I'm not gonna lie. Journalism. Fuck it, I'm falling back for that.
Do you recognize it now that you're older? I think he's got it. Thank you, Sean. No, I don't run for it. I don't run for it. You really? No. Really?
No, I really don't. It's just, you know, it's been part of my life for a long time and, you know, everything happens for a long time and everything happens for a reason. I had to go through that difficult time to maybe have the career that I had. I'm just saying, cause you're so mellow and cool and easy. Please tell my wife that. Please tell my wife that. It's also conditioned you well to be a great husband,
although she doesn't need any help navigating media, but a good father to help explain what some challenging stuff can be. Also a great owner for the team when some of these players start going through some of the same media scrutiny and stuff. So it's so great that you have a position that you've earned that is going to demand all of the things
you've had to create, manage, you know? Well, let me say this, David, let me ask you this, because this might help inform that if we can sort of backtrack. Are you, obviously you've done a lot, we've talked about a lot of these things, are you happy right now with where you are in life? I'm so happy.
Without crying, answer the question. Hang on. I'm sorry. I are in life? I'm so happy. Without crying, answer the question. Hang on. I am very happy. I'm very happy because I feel very blessed to have had the career that I've had and played for the teams that I have and experienced that.
And the one thing that I always wanted for me, I was lucky I met Victoria when I met her because I always wanted to have kids young because I always wanted to have kids young. I always wanted to have kids that lived through my career with me. And I was lucky the three boys all lived through most of the teams that I played for. That's really cool.
And that for me was a really important part of my life. Yes, and that was one of the coolest parts of the documentary when you were like, you looked at her on screen and you're like, I'm gonna marry that girl. I mean, that's crazy. And then you met her and then you married her. I mean, that's just nuts. And you're still married.
And you're still married, yeah. 20, 25 years in July. That's awesome. Well, that is awesome. And I guess the reason I ask that is because if you're happy and you seem like you are and you've got great kids and you're really close to them, that's evident, that really comes through. And you and your wife are really close.
But everybody goes through stuff in life, right? Like it's like you're always going to go through shit. I actually, you know what I quote all the time is, I don't know if you watch that All or Nothing, the Tottenham season, and Mourinho was on there for part of that, right? Yeah. It was great. I advise people to watch it. It's really good.
But I love one of the things that he said and is that he, I remember at halftime, he's talking to the players and he said, look, the other team is gonna score. They're gonna have possession. The question is, how do you cope? And if you can cope with that, you know, and it's true with life.
I think about it all the time. There are going to be times where you're not going to have your best day, where somebody else is going to get the thing you want, blah, blah, blah, blah. But how do you cope with it? And if at the end you end up being happy, then that was your journey. Yeah. And that's one of the things I think we both, me and Victoria, probably both get emotional about and after watching the documentary, after everything was over and we watched it finally,
that's the one thing that we looked at each other and was like, I don't know how we got through, you know, the last 27 years, but we did. And we have an amazing family, we have amazing businesses, and we're happy. And yeah, of course course when you're with someone for that amount of time Of course you have your ups and downs. Everybody knows that and at the end of the day We were lucky because we had each other at those moments, you know, she was a Spice girl I was playing for Manchester United and even when we were going through the difficult times we actually we actually had each other to feed off and And that was that was the that. And that was the best part.
We obviously, we were 21 and 22 when we met. We got married when we was 23 and 24. And we had our first son when he was 23. So as soon as we had our first son, Brooklyn, that really also added another layer to obviously the family and our responsibilities then were to our son. And those, you know. Now, let me ask you this.
You said businesses as well as family, which is really cool. How did you craft a business mind? Because a lot of sports figures don't have that side of their brain that gets exercised like that, or do they want to exercise that part of their brain? But you seem to gravitate towards it. What was, how did you do that?
I think throughout my career, I was lucky to go into different things, wherever it was being the face of certain brands and things like that. And I was able to work with great people over the years. I've been with Adidas for almost 30 years now. So a lot of the people and brands that I have and partners that I have are long-term partners.
So the business was something I was always interested in. Even from a young age, I knew that the moment I stopped playing, I wanted to have another life after that in the business world. And in all honesty, putting the Miami part was in, was a big part of the legacy that I wanted to leave, you know, in the game. You know, I wanted to be an owner of a team. I wanted to be in the U S.
Um, so if I got the opportunity to do that, that was what I wanted. But on the business side, you know, there's a lot of things that, that have continued throughout my business and I'm, I'm the business side, you know, there's a lot of things that have continued throughout my business. And I'm lucky to have, you know, the business that I have, but it's something that I always wanted to do. It's really impressive. Sean, you were saying that a lot of your partners were Adidas.
It was hard to see because it was dark, but... Yeah, yeah, yeah. David, are you traveling more now? Are you busier now than you ever were as a player? I'm so much more busy... busier than I was when I was a player because in all honesty... You're supposed to take it easy now. I know.
You're like everything I see, you're like in a different city, like opening a thing. I know, but I enjoy that part of it. I enjoy to travel, I enjoy to work, and in all honesty, that's a big part of my business. So that part of my life, I enjoy it. Yeah. David, my mother's British, so I love people who are British,
and I'd love to know what is the most quintessentially British thing about you? I love a roast. I love a roast dinner. Oh, that is probably the most quintessential part about me. Now that is a beef roast we're talking about, yes? Chicken roast. Chicken roast. I go for chicken roast. Yeah, I get it. I got it. Jason, when you came over for dinner, we had chicken roast. Yeah, we did. Yes, is that what you asked her to cook us? You like being in England, like on a Sunday, and having a proper roast dinner. It's my favorite thing to do. It's my favorite thing to do.
Do you like going for a pub lunch? Do you like on a Sunday? I do like a pub lunch. I like a pub lunch. And my kids love it. What bands? Because I love British band. I grew up on, Will did too, like on British pop
and stuff like that. Who do you listen to? Stone Roses. Love the Stone Roses, love the Stone Roses. I'm a big Stone Roses fan because obviously growing up in Manchester, in the 90s, it was all about Stone Roses, Oasis. Well Oasis is Man City though, sadly.
What is the best British slang word or phrase? And can you give us an example of how you'd use it? Oh, well, I was actually, my daughter started trying to ask me some slang the other day. She was like, dad, you always talk about these like slang words as a cockney. And I was like, okay, I'm trying to,
because I don't really want her to start talking slang in all honesty. So I was like, okay. So Harpy, you've just run up the apple and pears. And she was like, what do you mean? She was like, well, that's what it is. It's status. You know, you've just run up the apple and pears. So I've been trying...
Apple and pears? Yeah. Apple and pears. Yeah. Those kind of cockney, you know, slang she started to ask about. But, you know, Victoria would kill, but Victoria would kill me. She would kill me, but if I was trying to teach her those kind of words and things, she would be happy.
You're obviously still staying in incredible shape. What about some of that British food there? What's your favorite piece of crap over there in England? Would it be something like that? I'm from the East End of London, so I grew up on it's pie and mash. So it's simple. It's a mint pie. It's your most simple mash.
No butter, just salt. And then it's like a gravy called liquor. And it's stewed eels and parsley. I'll do that. I'll do that.'s stewed eels and parsley. And then jelly eels. So jelly eels is eels. So you cut up eels and then- Eel like the fish, the snake?
The fish, the sea snake? Yep, yep, in gelatin. In gelatin. Oh, good Lord. It's not for everyone, it's not for everyone, but that's- Not for anyone. David, you've been a very, very nice man to join us and a great man during this interview.
I love you. You're the best. What a thrill. What an absolute thrill, man. It's a thrill for me to be on here. I'm a big fan of all you guys and obviously what you do. And to be on here is a huge privilege So thank you set the bar very high for Victoria to try to jump over
She'll kill it in a second. Don't worry. We can't wait to have it He said to me you can bring the looks and I'm bringing the humor. That's Her words not mine, let's let's all let's all have bangers and all that stuff without the eel when you're here. Well, you're invited to come to Miami or when you come to London and we'll go to a pie mash. I would love that, I would love that. Fantastic.
Great. Thanks, pal. You're welcome. David, thank you so, so much. Have a great rest of your night. Thank you very much. Off to the families. Oh, cheers, me too.
And have fun at the premiere. Thank you. Yes, sir. Thank you, I will. Take care, bye. Bye, David. Off to the families. Oh, cheers, me too. And have fun at the premiere. Thank you. Yes, sir. Thank you, I will. Take care, bye. Bye, buddy. That was incredible. Also, I'm good for your birthday, Christmas.
That was incredible. Yeah, wow, I did not see that coming. Me neither. I was like, oh, I'm not gonna know who the soccer player, I'm not gonna know who the soccer player. When you kept saying, like, Will, you're gonna know, I'm like, what is he talking about? But you know, to our listeners out there, we...
We got Shani back on, like we got Shani again. But like, so to our listeners like me and Sean, we're not big soccer fans, but we make a commitment to you in the audience that if we're gonna bring somebody on that does something you have no idea about, they're gonna be charming, they're going to be uber famous, okay, and they're gonna walk you through it. They're gonna answer all your questions. And by the way, sometimes they're not gonna be any of those things.
Yeah, sometimes they're. Okay, and then we just won't air those episodes. What are you, a lawyer or something? We've got a can full of them. But JB, you know what was great about him, and you kinda hit it on the head, which is he was able to articulate exactly what we wanna know about him, right? Yes. So you ask him, and he what was great about him, and you kind of hit it on the head, which is he was able to articulate exactly what we want to know about him, right?
So you ask him, and he's so open, real, and I love that, and it's evident that he's, I think it's part of being English, so that he's very down to earth. And he's so charming. He's not over his skis, he's very in tune with his family, and he's just down to earth, so he can talk in a way that's very accessible.
Yeah, that's why I'm like, well, how are you so mellow? Yeah, it's not, Sean, it's not hard. If you just smile a little bit, Sean. I know, I'm just like, hug, hug, hug. And just get out into the world, too. You know what I mean? He's a guy who's out doing shit. You're exhausted if you go to Larchmont.
Like, what are you? You know it's so sad, that is true. It's fucking true. This guy's going all over the world. You know what's so sad? That is true. It's fucking true. This guy's going all over the world. You know what? He's getting into the world. He's out there, man. No, here's the other thing.
Every time you guys said MLS, I was like, ooh, real estate. I thought you were talking about real estate. Exactly, yeah. I got so excited about like. Right. Was he sending a listing? By the way, maybe we can.
Can I see photos? I'm so giddy at the thought of... I mean, I guess I'm now a Miami fan because I really like that. I think I'm a Miami fan. Even though Farrell's gonna be mad because he's an LAFC guy, we love Will a lot.
We like the battle. And we like the battle. So we don't want to get in trouble with that. But right now, we want to help David. We're gonna help. Jürgen Klopp to Miami. I will fucking... Don't let him get in the tears again.
Well, if that happens though, Willie, then you'll have, well, but you'll be an LA FC fan, and then you'll be a Miami fan. Yes. So basically your fandom will be literally by... CROSSROAD! I was gonna say, you're gonna be so excited. Thank god we cut before that.
That was fucking rad. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarff, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. SmartList If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. What if your partner developed 21 new identities? Or you discovered that your friend who helped you through the darkest times was actually
a conniving con artist? Or what if you began seeing demons everywhere, inhabiting people around you, including your son? What would you do? I'm Whit Misseldine, the creator of This Is Actually Happening, a podcast that brings you extraordinary true stories of life-changing events, told by the people who lived them. In our newest season, you'll hear even more intimate first-person accounts of how regular people have overcome remarkable circumstances, like the man who went to jail for 17 years
for accidentally shooting the person who tried to save his life, to a close friend of the infamous scam artist, Amanda Riley. These haunting accounts sound like Hollywood movies, but I assure you, this is actually happening. Follow This Is Actually Happening on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts, and you can listen to This Is Actually Happening ad-free on Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.